alex because of that recent spike you
referenced in coronavirus cases governor
steve silac is now imposing a three week
what he calls
a pause yeah he's stressing this is not
a shutdown but it will include more
restrictions on businesses and even
private gatherings
kristin drummond live on the strip this
morning with some of those new rules
good morning christian
good morning alex the statewide pause is
actually strengthening the mass mandate
governor steve sislak wants everyone to
wear a mask
when not around people in your immediate
household so that means
inside outside as well as at private
gatherings
this is just one of the many targeted
approaches to try and reduce our
covet case positivity rate now there are
other restrictions as well
that are going to impact restaurants as
well as fast food places
he's requiring to reduce capacity from
50 percent to 25 percent
also guests must book a reservation that
includes places in casinos
no walk-ins are allowed and no more than
four customers at a table
governor syslack encourages anyone not
actively eating or drinking to
wear a mask at the table we spoke to
lucy's bar at the lucky club casino
about the new guidelines and
staff say they're ready to comply
i'm really good with it i want this to
go away and i know it's not going to but
if we clo
you know cut down again maybe we can get
a handle on this
as far as enforcement goes governor
sislak seems to be leaving it up to
local jurisdictions he also referred to
agencies
like osha which investigate if issues
are reported
now brothel strip clubs day clubs as
well as nightclubs will remain closed
but these additional changes are not
going to be impacting
nail hair salons massage places as
well as spas now the statewide pause
goes into effect at 1201
tuesday morning reporting live on the
strip kristen drummond
8 news now